in the early stages of the midterm cycle
Speaker Ryan has been crisscrossing the
country the Speaker of the House Speaker
Paul Ryan raising money convincing
donors to write more than 40 million
dollars worth of checks to help House
Republicans maintain their majority so
why retire I really don't think a
person's race for Congress is going to
hinge on whether Paul Ryan's speaker or
not so I really don't think it affects
it the National Republican Congressional
Committee led by Congressman Steve
Stivers is now assessing how Ryan's
departure affects its bottom line I
believe his donor base is connected to
him and will stick with him even when
he's not running for speaker but you
know we'll see what happens they're in
really tight races and cummins think
voters will care more about local issues
than an outgoing speaker I'm not sure it
has that much impact to be perfectly
honest with you my race is so unique its
to my district Ryan is one of 26
Republicans retiring from politics 13
others are leaving to pursue different
offices but the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee which has been
predicting Ryan would retire thinks he's
just getting out because he quote sees
what is coming in November Paul Ryan is
bailing unfortunately for House
Republicans they all are still stuck
with this agenda that agenda may
determine which Republican is picked to
succeed Ryan one possibility
Majority Whip Steve Scalise I think
what's most important is that we stay
focused on working with President Trump
to get our economy back on track
another possibility Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy we've got a lot of work
to do and focus on keeping the majority
about a speaker right that's why
Republicans don't see a speaker's race
impacting November's contests with one
exception the one place it might have
some impact is if people are speculating
that Nancy Pelosi might be speaker it
might motivate our base Democrats insist
they've got the motivated base and that
if Ryan thought Republicans would still
be in the majority this time next year
he wouldn't be leaving but Republicans
believe the retirement is a one-day
story